موعد السودانيين مع وقف نهائي للقتال يبقى
مؤجلا وكافه الرصاصي لا تزال هي الارجح
على الاقل حتى الان المشهد في العاصمه
يبدو مخيفا محل اقفلها اصحابها بعد نفاذ
المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه منها وتوقف
اسواق الجمله عن العمل ومحل البقاله
القليله التي لا تزال تعمل تكاد تخلو من
البضائع والمتوفر منها تفوق اسعاره قدره
المواطن العادي حلو على حاصله يعني بكل
جهه لا كهرباء ولا مويه يمكن يشد يعني هنا
والخبز اهو
اربعين دقيقه بين اربعين الى 60 دقيقه
عشان تقدر اشيل لك
عشر عشرين عيشه
الحمد لله
حامدون وشاكرون رغم قسوه الصراع والاوضاع
الاقتصاديه الصعبه
ما بنقدر نجي منه حاجه لانه في استغلال
يعني حتى لو الباكو بتاع الدقيقه الليله ب
8000 هيديك له قريبا من محل
طوابير السيارات هذه وكانها بلا نهايه في
ام درمان تصطفوا الى جانب محطات الوقود
رغم يقين اصحابها بخلو تلك الخزانات من اي
وقود ولو توفرت فالاسعار المطلوبه غير
متوفره
ازمات السودانيين تتضاعف مع الانقطاع
المتكرر لخدمات الانترنت والاتصالات
الهاتفيه فضلا عن شرح السيوله النقديه
واغلاق البنوك لتبقى اصوات الرصاص
المتقطعه في هدنه هشه لتزيد مخاوف
السودانيين من اطاله امد الصراع حنان
المصري العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات